the “night parrot”, is often described
by ornithologists as being the most mysterious
and enigmatic bird on Earth- a moniker the
night parrot earned by being so rare and elusive
that fewer people alive today have seen one
with their own eyes than have ever walked
on the Moon.
Described bluntly by one of the few people
to have handled one as a “dumpy oversized
budgie”, the unassuming greenish-yellow
bird is endemic to Australia, with confirmed
sightings largely being limited to the deserts
of Western Australia and Queensland.
Unusually for a bird that is capable of lengthy
and extremely fast flight, the night parrot
spends much of its time on the ground hiding
amongst the brush and shrubland of the Australian
outback, making the species one of only three
known “ground parrots” as they’re commonly
known.
That said, a very recent tagging of one of
these birds which provided GPS data for the
animal for 15 days demonstrated that, as mentioned,
the night parrot can cover a lot of ground
very quickly, with the shortest distance the
tracked bird flew in one night being approximately
40 kilometres (about 24 miles).
As for this travel, it would seem the purpose
behind it is generally to find water.
Its food, on the other hand, is speculated
to be things likes the seeds of Triodia grasses
that it likes to hide in.
Speaking of its nocturnal movements, as you
may have guessed given the night parrot’s
name, the bird is described as being a mostly
nocturnal creature, generally hiding in tall
foliage during the day, with their coloring
patterns blending in well with such shrubbery.
First “discovered” in 1845 by members
of an expedition trying to find a “mythical
sea” that supposedly existed somewhere in
the heart of Australia (an amazing story we’ll
no doubt cover another day), the bird was
seemingly quite common at the time, with over
a dozen specimens being easily collected in
the 1870s alone.
In fact, the indigenous Maiawali people are
known to have once made extensive use of the
night parrot’s feathers for ceremonial clothing.
For reasons experts can’t quite agree on
though, around the turn of 20th century the
bird almost completely disappeared, with the
last live specimen caught in that century
being captured sometime in 1912.
As to where the bird went, it’s speculated
it was simply displaced by humans or perhaps
hunted to near extinction by feral and domestic
cats, but nobody really knows.
In fact, there have been some who have speculated
that perhaps the bird isn’t endangered at
all; it’s just extremely good at hiding.
That said, after that 1912 capture of a live
specimen, while amateur bird watchers sporadically
claimed sightings of the parrot, as the century
stretched on with no well documented sightings
occurring despite many pro bird-nerds conducting
extensive searches, many experts began to
write-off the bird as being extinct.
Not willing to accept this, in 1989 Australian
businessman, entrepreneur, and conservationist
Dick Smith offered a $25,000 reward to anyone
who could provide proof that the bird was
still out there somewhere.
A year later, this proof was found almost
entirely by accident when three ornithologists
decided to randomly pull over to pee while
driving through south-west Queensland.
During their little wizz break, they stumbled
upon a dead night parrot by the side of the
road.
As if that wasn’t fortunate enough, it’s
noted that the only reason the ornithologists
were even able to identify the bird at all
is because two of them just so happened to
be “among a handful of people in the world
to have handled stuffed night parrots”.
Dick Smith dutifully paid the men the reward
money (which they in turn donated to the university
they all worked for) and Australia’s ornithologists
once again began searching for the night parrot
with vigor.
The next reasonably well documented sighting
occurred in 2005 when a pair of biologists
claim to have spotted not one, but three night
parrots while the scientists were studying
a region for potential iron ore mining.
A much better documented sighting occurred
in 2006 when another specimen was found dead
by a park ranger, Robert Cupitt, working in
Diamantina National Park.
Oddly, this bird was found without a head,
seemingly flying into a barbed wire fence
at high speed and, it is generally thought,
decapitating itself.
However, a search for the bird’s head proved
fruitless, and it is possible the bird simply
had its head eaten off by some wild animal
or it was otherwise eaten after it was removed
by the fence wire.
Whatever the case, after several more years
of nothing but unsubstantiated reports of
the night parrot from enthusiastic bird watchers,
wildlife photographer and ornithologist John
Young became the first human in over a century
to definitely have seen a living night parrot
when he managed to snap a photo of one in
2013.
By his own estimation, Young spent some 15
years and around 17,000 hours searching for
the bird in the Australian outback, eventually
managing to get a handful of photos of one,
a few seconds of footage of it in flight,
and sound recordings of its call.
(For the curious, the night parrot is variously
described as sounding like everything from
a bell going “ding ding” to a croaking
frog.)
Since 2013, several more confirmed sightings
of live night parrots have been recorded with
an ecologist called Dr Steve Murphy even managing
to capture one and tag it for study in 2015.
Murphy caught the bird (which he affectionately
called Pedro) with the help of his wife Rachel,
but refused to divulge where exactly Pedro
was spotted except to a select few, including
fellow ecologists, ornithologists and academics.
(You can see a picture of the night parrot
here.)
Seemingly the information must also have been
divulged to some politicians, because to protect
Pedro and his kin, the Pullen Pullen Reserve
was established consisting of some 56,000
hectares of land in Queensland around the
area Murphy found him.
However, the exact location of the reserve
has never been publicly released because of
course Australia has empty areas of land so
vast that they can reserve approximately 140,000
acres (560 kilometres squared) for wildlife
without needing to tell the public where it
is.
The night parrot is considered to be at great
risk of predation from feral cats and as a
result, the Pullen Pullen Reserve has a number
of special traps designed specifically to
targets cats and nothing else.
These traps use cameras and a proprietary
algorithm to detect cats based on their gait
and size, at which point a toxic gel is sprayed
at the animal’s face.
The idea being that when the cat grooms itself,
it will ingest the gel
and die.
We are not making that up.